Today, we're going to learn a little bit about, uh, this molecule here,
this crazy complex looking piece of molecular architecture,
which is called strychnine, which no doubt you probably will have heard of.
It's a well-known poison these days it's used for killing rats,
but in the past it was a medicinal compound, especially in the Victorian area.
So at that point in time, uh, it was used for all sorts of ailments,
like headaches. It was, uh,
one of the very first athletic performance enhancers, believe it or not.
And of course it's,
it's a poison it's really not useful in any of these respects whatsoever.
It comes from the seeds of a tree in the Philippines. And,
uh, hundreds of years, the Filipinos would use the extracts of this.
So being as they called the seed to treat various elements.
So it was a sort of herbal type of medicine and it works on the nervous system.
So it give you a bit of a tingle, um, obviously in high doses or,
or actually not that high doses, um,
it'll have very severe effects on you, but if, if something, he takes something,
it interacts in your body,
you get a bit of a tingle and perhaps you feel like it's doing good rather than
harm. So in small quantities, uh, it was used for centuries,
but actually is it's got no real beneficial effect, uh,
as a medicine and indeed, you know, famously it's been used, uh,
in all sorts of murder mystery cases.
I have just one story about straightening,
but I really like it just before I started as a PhD
student,
a Brazilian professor visiting the chemistry department,
took some strict Nene out to the store because he wanted to poison his
wife, but being a professor,
he was a bit types and minded and he mislaid the threatening. He lost it.
And he got really worried that somebody might get poisoned
other than his wife.
So he went to the police and admitted everything.
And then the strict Nene was found in his jacket pocket hanging in his
wardrobe. So his wife was safe.
What happened to the professor? I have no idea.
I find as a Stanford university is poisoned by strict being murdered by
straightening. And the,
her last words were that this is the most horrible and painful death
and fiction.
It's been used a lot and I get the Christie three or four novels of hers had
strict coming in in the grand Budapest hotel. It's in there as a, as a poison.
Actually,
there hasn't been many deaths or murders through the use of strict strychnine.
Uh, luckily, so this was given to us by Sigma Aldrich, uh, for the use in,
uh, the periodic videos. So thank you very much to them. Yeah.
It was about a gram in here and it takes about 10 to 50 milligrams to,
to kill human beings. This tree gives a beautiful white flowers, uh,
very fragrant smelling. Um,
but presumably it's in there to stop animals from eating the seeds, you know,
animal takes a bite of it and doesn't finish its meal.
Like many of the campaigns that I talk about it works on the nervous system
means that you or your muscles go out of control. And you know,
you dive as fixation of, uh,
not being able to breathe because your lungs aren't working properly.
Imagine it is a series of electrical cables with junction boxes in between.
And at the end is he got sensors and muscles at the other end.
So sensors built up using irons,
a concentration of positive charge using generally sodium potassium,
calcium mines that then finds an electrical charge down the cable to the other
end and then calcium mines allowing the release of neurotransmitters to go and
tell the muscle or the brain or whatever's on the other end, what to do.
So this interferes with that process at the junction boxes.
So this inhibits both sodium and chlorine iron channels, which is unusual.
Normally a molecule will interact with just one type of receptor.
Whereas this is interacts with two types of receptor.
How does it actually get there? Yeah, that's a good question.
So if you ingest something, it'll go obviously into your gut.
Once it's in the gut,
it can then pass through the guts of blood barrier needs to be charged to do
that. So we've got basic aiming on here.
It then gets into your bloodstream in the bloodstream,
then transports it around your body.
This obviously with the blood will go to all your muscles and start to interfere
with any, uh, neuromuscular junctions that, that it comes across.
It's not a very good murder weapon because it will stay in the body for years
traces of it. So it'd be very easily identifiable.
No, it's a new one. Just strictly tastes like, well,
they say it takes bitten. And, uh, on the strict name, uh,
this is tertiary aiming here. This, this blue action, uh,
in anything with a tertiary aiming, always tastes incredibly better. A lot,
a lot of insects are these tertiary Amy molecules on
the back so that they taste horrible.
So a bit like I'm licking a brass or copper spoon. Yeah. Really bitter and
really not very pleasant at all. So again, not,
not the best poison cause you get to taste it in your cup of tea.
Here we are. We'll open the bank, the, uh,
high security containment system and just take a little look at what the
straightening looks like so that we have the chop.
There's not a lot in here. Actually. I was maybe it maybe a hundred milligrams.
No, not at all. Let's just take that.
There we go. So there we go.
Just a, a white
powder essentially looks fairly innocuous.
I mean the majority of chemicals that you work with are not toxic. Uh,
there may be, it was so-called harmful,
maybe slightly crazy for majority. Uh, uh, not that way.
So I wouldn't want my PhD students to it with anything that's extremely
toxic. Um,
although we have made a few natural products over the years, which,
which are really quite potent,
but this is quite dangerous substance and not something that the likes of which
we would normally.
Be working with. I look at that and I think, wow, that's beautiful,
such a really unique architecture. All of these rings systems,
you've got hydrogens pointing into this cavity here.
Seven membered rings, five of them had rings.
Six members rings all sorts of different molecular architectural pieces in
there. And for the synthetic chemists that makes this an absolutely outstanding
challenge. This is the Everest,
if you like of the total synthesis type of world.
So as isolated by two French chemists in 1818.
So, you know, nearly 200 years ago now, uh,
and it was about 120 years later by the time chemists had
figured,
finally figured out what on earth the structure was because it's just so
complex. So there were over a hundred,
250 papers attempting to find out what the structure of
straightening was. And eventually in 1947, uh, two chemists, uh,
Robert Robinson who is later became sir Robert Robinson at Oxford university.
He proposed the correct structure and, uh,
Luke's a completely separate chemist. Also debit.
Rob Robinson was very famous in his day and this was a combination of two
decades worth of work in his laboratories. Seven years later,
Robert Burns Woodward was the first group to synthesize it. And,
uh, Robin Hanson had said for its molecular size,
it's the most complex molecule ever known since Woodward's original synthesis
has been 17 further syntheses.
So 1954 was the first synthesis as was around 28 synthetic steps.
So different things that you had to do and the yield was minuscule. It was, uh,
there was starting from tens of kilos and getting milligrams, Oh, Oh,
Oh, Oh 6% yield, which is a very small amount.
And quite a lot of steps.
28 steps actually is for the complexity of this molecule is still quite
competitive. The next synthesis was carried out in 1992.
So it was many years later, uh, by Phillip Magnus. That was again 28 steps,
but he got up to point over 3% yield. It's considerably more efficient,
about a thousand times more efficient, but still a very low yield in each case.
Um, all of these people, uh, were developing a new type of bond connection,
connecting reaction, and they are putting that into operation. So Magnus in,
in his synthesis was making this bond in this bond and the key step using a
deals, all the type of, uh, Woodward had used a, um,
obviously that the synthetic chemistry of the day in, in, you know,
40 years have passed by the time Magnus, uh,
came to doing it in 1994 was the next synthesis.
And that one went up to 3% yield using Larry omens chemistry.
And these are all, you know, incredible.
These are the rock stars of the organic chemistry world that are coming to play
here. Uh, so, uh,
time moves on 2007 Padre. I've got it down to 16 steps,
2% yield by 2011,
we had the shortest census ever nine steps by Chris van Duval, terrible yield.
There was one really difficult step in there,
but nine steps when you think the original was 28, um,
it was quite incredible and probably the best synthesis out there is by David
McMillan, 12 steps, but 6% yield.
So considerably stronger and thousand times more efficient than the original
synthesis.
And this is the progress that organic chemistry has made not only in structural
elucidation.
So 20 years worth of work in the 1930s and forties,
250 papers to determine the structure of this
today.
One of my PhD students will be able to determine the structure in an afternoon
because spectroscopic techniques have come an incredibly long way.
There were almost none back in 1946, we had infrared,
there was an x-ray of this in 1952.
So that was one of the very first x-rays, but in 1946, that didn't exist.
So back then they had to literally chemically react it and figure
out what, uh,
bonds would have been broken through that type of reaction.
So it was a real detective story back when using evidence chemical evidence to
determine structure. Whereas now we can use spectroscopy.
Can I happen to that now? Well,
I'll put some of that back in the bottle and the rest we'll have we'll destroy
and then sit on a shelf for a certain lot cupboard. Yeah.
Just in case we get some ramps in the, uh, the lab.
Uh, but every few seconds, your brain's saying, breathe in, breathe out,
breathe in, breathe out. It does it automatically, or, or move your muscles.
So if you stop any of those signals, then obviously it muscles stop.
And if you stop breathing, you're going to die pretty quick.